TO BEAT ME.
>> Mike: ERIC LEWIS GOES OVER
AND LOOKING FOR AN
>> Chr DENVER
NUGGETS.S HERE IN THE
BUBBLE.
BALL.OR THE LAKERS AS
WELL.
>> Brian: NOWLL-POPE THOUGHT HEE
ONE BEINGER NOW ON LeBRON JAMES.
>> Reggie: GOOD LUCK.WANT TO SE
FIRST-TEAM ALL-NBA PERFOR
JAME
MURRAY. GIVE.
JOKIC TRYING TO DISRUPT RONDO.
HE PUTS
THREES HERE IN THIS FOURTH
QUARTER.
>> Brian: THEY CONFIRM THE
DOUBLE-TEAMING.
I'M SAYING RUDY GOBERT, YOU GOT
SAYS THAT'S OKAY, I
YOU HAVE TO TRUST YOUR GAME.
>> Mar SHOT.
JA HARRIS.
MURRAY SWITCHES
>> Mark Jackson: YOU DON'T WANT
A FOUL.
MAKE HIM WORK FOR HIS
HE LOST IT.
THE NUGGETS COME UP WITH THE  GT
OUOUTT A AGAGAININSTST L LAKAKE
>>>> R Regeggigie:e: B BACACK-K!
BIBIGG H HITIT R RIGIGHTHT T TH
MOMORRRRISIS..
BABACKCK T TOO A A G GUYUYS S
FRFROMOM T THEHE B BENENCHCH F
HAHAVEVE  GUGUTSTS..
HEHERERE W WEE  ENENDIDINGNG M S
TOTO T THEHE F FREREE-E-LALAYEY.
PUPUTSTS T THAHATT  ININ..
LILIKEKE W WEE R REBEBOUOUNDND
THTHERERE.E.
FIFIRSRSTT R REBEBOUOUNDND
>>>> K Kevevinin:: L LeBeBRORON.
LALAKEKERSRS M MADADEE M MOROREM
ANANDD B BYY  GEGEICICO.O.
1515 M MININUTUTESES C COUOULDL
>>>> K Kevevinin:: W WHAHATT D
SNSNYDYDERER T T T
>>>> K Kevevinin:: TWTWO-O-POPT
TOTO G GOO L LONONGG 1 11 1
REREBOBOUNUNDSDS A ANDND F FIVI
ABABSOSOLULUTETE L LASASTT    M.
>>>> K Kevevinin:: W WHAHATTDED.
MIMITCTCHEHELLLL I ISS O OUTUT .
CLCLARARKSKSONON I IS S OUOUOU
FIFIRSRST T RERESTSTARART T GAG,
HAHASNSN'T'T P PLALAYEYED,D, P
O OFFFF T THEHE S SLILIPP  SCS
TOTONYNY B BRARADLDLEYEY..
LOLOOKOK A AT T THTHISIS..
COCOASAST.T.
PLPLENENTYTY O OFF O OPPPPORORT
KLEBER.
IN AND OUT.
THAT LOOKED LIKE IT WAS GO NS TO
BOUNCE IN.
AND GEORGE GIT THAT OPEN SHOT, T
HISTORY OF THE RIGHT NOW.
OF DONCIC.
DONCIC PULLS UP.
>>>> M Marark:k: T THIHISS T TIS
NSNSIVIVE.E.
>>>> M Mikike:e: M McCcCOLOLLUL
ININ T THEHE F FOUOURTRTH H QUQ.
>>>> M Mikike:e: A A D DYNYNAMA
McMcCOCOLLLLUMUM A ANDNDNDT T A
THTHEMEM P PLALAY.Y. T THEHE
GRGRIZIZZLZLIEIESS T THEHEY'Y'R
BABASKSKETETBABALLLL..
FOFOURUR B BLALAZEZERSRS W WITIT
ITIT F FOR